Hi! I'm Ana.
Welcome to 'What to Say!'
Do you know what to say when you meet new people?
Listen out for useful language for meeting new people.
Then, we'll practise saying the new phrases –
after this.
Hi.
Hello.
Are you Paul?
No, I'm not.
But he asked me to meet you.
I'm Emir.
You must be Vanya.
Yes, I am.
Nice to meet you.
You too.
Can I show you the office?
Perfect.
Thanks.
So how was your journey?
It was fine
and it's great to be here!
Well, it's great to have you here.
Can I get you a coffee?
Oh, yes, please.
Ah, Yuna,
this is Vanya.
Oh, hi, I'm Yuna. Nice to meet you.
Welcome to the team!
Hello again!
That went well.
OK,
did you notice the useful phrases used for meeting new people?
Listen to me and then repeat.
Hi, I'm Yuna.
You must be Vanya.
Nice to meet you.
You too.
This is Vanya.
So how was your journey?
It's great to be here!
Welcome to the team!
Try and use some of these phrases the next time you meet new people in English.
Bye for now!